christian thank you a new countdown
begins for some clark county school
district
secondary students and educators
returning to campus this month
6th 9th and 12th graders go back march
22nd
the district expects most ccsd staff and
buildings on the 15th of march
kristen drummond showing us how
educators are getting ready to return
next week will you be going back into
the classroom on monday
i will i'm really excited vaccinated and
ready to go
i've had both my shots so i feel a
little safer that way
and i'm gonna wear my mask kim ritzer
prepares for
another big adjustment the choirs
director at green valley high school
needs to pack up her home
office i have a monitor a big monitor
television monitor and stuff
and move items back to campus next week
part of the transition to start hybrid
learning for middle schools
and high schools i'm excited to get back
into my classroom
with a real piano other ccsd educators
also anticipating the big day following
a year of distance education
most teachers have not been back in
buildings since last
march some returned in the fall to teach
students online from their classrooms
but started working remotely in november
following the governor's
stay at home 2.0 plan during a spike in
coveted cases in the community
it's going to be strange for sure it's
going to be strange i will see the date
from last year
up on my board i will see my objectives
and lesson plans and
just things about school dances or
whatever from last year
classrooms frozen in time now requiring
teachers to organize them before
students return in two weeks my
classroom right now is still a mess
i plan on fixing that up next week part
of the preparations to start hybrid
learning and the changes coming with
that
kristin drummond 8 news now now some
teachers say receiving the vaccination
makes them much more confident to return
to school buildings denise